have you had a dream of going full time
on youtube maybe you've even thought
about working for a youtube channel as
think media right now is in a season of
hiring an expansion starting our
internship program and expanding to more
people on the team this is becoming a
reality for more and more people and in
today's episode of the youtube made
simple show i have my friend rob from
vidiq and we're going to be walking
through his journey of actually becoming
the face of a youtube channel and
growing it to over a million subscribers
all that and more is coming up on
today's episode of the youtube made
simple show
[Music]
welcome to today's episode i am so
excited and fired up to get to interview
a colleague and a friend rob from vid iq
and today's episode is actually brought
to you in partnership with vid iq if
you've not yet signed up for your free
30-day trial you can do that at
vidiq.com
forward slash think and when you sign up
with that link you will actually get
access to 30 days free so you can go to
vidiq.com forward slash think well i am
joined by the none other than rob from
vid iq hey rob how you doing hey heather
happy new year to you and happy new year
to all of the think media rights here uh
you did made me trickle when you said i
i'm the face of vid iq i feel as if i'm
now an ever evolving face since uh i
joined i now have a beard and glasses so
who knows what i'm gonna look like in
five years time i know it's it is
amazing that video will capture our
evolution right i mean we look back at
videos when you first got started when i
first got started online and we're
baby-faced rob you know we're little
kids just kind of coming up in the ranks
and it's so cool to see but happy new
year to you as well rob and really i
want to know from think media we were
discussing this before how long can you
say
happy new year after the new year we're
going to put a poll up here i want you
to vote because you know i think we
should go all the way until february rob
what do you think
i think the first two weeks of january i
think is sufficient for me but in north
america it's a little bit different
because like we have a tradition in the
uk where we have to take down all of our
christmas decorations 12 days after
christmas but in canada i still still
people having christmas trees up in the
middle of april so
you you do what you do in north america
but i'm going for two weeks two weeks
you know we are a family that keeps our
decorations we have all of our christmas
decorations up still they come down two
weeks after yeah so we are that same
family and if isaiah my husband had his
way rob christmas would be every day of
the year and so we would we would be
that family that would have lights up
and a christmas tree up and so i'm
excited it looks like uh january 6th
that's what how we get uh genealogy says
um january 6 seems to be a cutoff date
that makes sense it's about a week in so
a vote
on the poll or let us know in the
comments if you're watching rob i have
been so looking forward to this
conversation and interview because you
know i think this is we are kind of in a
new school environment you and i both
work for youtube channels where we are
the face of them and i i would love to
break down your journey what did that
look like for you because this is a
solid career for maybe someone who has
their own youtube channel right now and
they're really doing it as a solopreneur
right they're by themselves doing all of
it i always say at the end of a movie
when you see all those credits when
you're a youtuber you are all those
people and so um i want to walk through
kind of where you started how you got to
where you are and then and then we'll
jump into a couple other questions but
why don't for the people who are just
meeting you right now rob why don't you
just let them know who you are um and a
little bit about that start of your
journey to youtube
yeah so where i am today at the
beginning of 2022 is a self-made title
which is a youtuber in residence
vid iq which essentially means i run a
youtube channel so i am a video creator
representing vid iq
i started my journey on youtube i
believe
2008 i'm sure when you ask people who've
been on on youtube for a while they can
never remember
their exact start date when they made
their first video but it feels like for
me
i had a
a light introduction to youtube when i
decided to make a couple of videos
but nothing really happened from them or
i didn't think that was the case
and at the time i was very naive and i
must confess i kind of did a mash-up of
some material that would have probably
been considered copyrighted in the
future you know fair play did that count
i'm not sure and then i didn't make any
videos i would say for a good number of
years
but what was happening was uh i would
just be going about my daily business
and i keep getting emails saying
somebody else has subscribed to your
youtube channel
and it was clear although i didn't
realize this it was clear that people
were watching my videos and subscribing
and then wanted to see something else
from me and i wasn't actually on youtube
so i didn't start taking youtube more
seriously i would say until 2011 which
is when i
pivoted onto a very specific topic which
was tech
and i guess the rest is history uh from
that point onwards when i was starting
to make tech channel uh tech videos
and so you started making tech videos
and um you were you were on your own
right rob this was like where you were
working a full-time job and doing this
on the side or was this your full-time
gig at the time growing that tech
channel what did that look like for you
so i think the history of me starting my
youtube um channel and wanting to make
content was
a need for me to
express myself creative creatively
i would describe myself originally as a
failed writer i went to university and
studied english with creative writing
because i wanted to be
a journalist or maybe maybe write books
but the thing that i found really
difficult was to get noticed and most
importantly have feedback i did interns
and i i think i wrote like 100 articles
for the local bbc website at the time
i'm sure everybody's heard of a bbc
but no point in those two or three years
did i really get any
valuable feedback from the audience who
was reading those articles or the people
i was writing the articles for
and you know as well as i know and
everybody else here youtube gives you
all of that you get feedback from
everything that you make through data
and you get comments from your audience
so i found youtube as a perfect platform
to
um experiment with my creativity i had
no idea i had an interest in making
video content until i started doing it
and once i'd found my niche in tech
then i was really able to start going
forward with making content but it
wasn't for another couple of years i
really found my my super niche you know
people say you niche within a niche
within a niche to begin with i was just
making videos about android tablets or
android apps going here and everywhere
tutorials
and i stumbled upon
a specific tutorial about how to record
your iphone screen uh which was
relatively difficult at the time ios
didn't do it natively so you had to get
apps from outside of
the app store
and i made one video on that and again i
had that experience of six months 12
months later people were subscribing and
watching that video and i thought you
know what let's just try and pivot to
this one topic and see if i can make a
dozen videos on that really specific
need from an audience of how to record
your iphone screen and somehow i turn
that into like 100 150 videos which
sounds
insane how can you make so much content
on one thing but if you really put in
the research and you really respond to
your own audience you can make content
on a specific thing from all sorts of
different angles and that was where i
i discovered the concept of really being
the ambassador of a leader all the or
the representative for a particular
topic on youtube and begin to dominate
that space
so many key points in there that you
talked about one was this didn't happen
over night right like it takes time it
takes the ability to be making videos to
be failing at videos to get that one
that you're like wow this might actually
work and it really starts to
um to grow from there rob talk to me
about what it was like to grow your
channel solo
as a creator i think yeah i just
described that like three or four years
worth of effort and experience you know
500 videos
um so it was it was a wonderful thing to
just have people watching my content
and
i was never really interested in the
ability to make money uh for the first
couple of years
uh i don't know if you remember this
heather but the the monetization
requirements used to be ten thousand
views and people are probably dropping
their jaws at this point figuring wow
that sounds incredibly easy and i guess
today right rob back in the day
i guess it was but i wasn't paying
attention to that milestone i just got
an email one day saying you've been
invited to the youtube partner program
or whatever it was called at that point
and it's like great yeah i'll sign up
for that all right i'm earning a dollar
a day a two dollars a day but again that
didn't really interest me i was much
more interested in getting
300 views today instead of 200 views
yesterday
so the struggle wasn't really money it
was finding time and i'm sure all of you
amateur
non-full-time doing this in your
free time creators understand this that
after a full day of
work
in your job and then all of the other
live stuff
you're physically exhausted
but
if you really want to make a thing of
youtube then you have to find time or
dedicate some of your energy to that
pursuit and that's effectively what i
started doing
um you know i do my nine-to-five job i
get home i'd spend a couple of hours
making a video so the quality wasn't
that good because i didn't have the time
but i was determined to be consistent
get one video out a day and so on i
remember there was one point where um my
wife would leave for work in the morning
at eight o'clock and i would smash out a
video as quickly as i could in 45
minutes and then cycle to work and then
i come back and maybe try and fresh out
another video so i was doing like two or
three videos a day so i could schedule
schedule them out
and it was a grind
but i discovered my passion i discovered
that i loved making youtube content
irrespective of whether i was paid for
it
and uh one thing you said there it was
the grind and we just finished a series
here on the podcast all about kind of
the seasons that you go through and that
was really the season of sacrifice and i
feel like so many content creators
wanted to just instantaneously happen
once they make one video and i mean you
were doing this before work after work i
mean this is when you throw yourself
into a passion and and into this and
thinking about it as it could be a
career you really do have to go through
those seasons and you know we were we
were coaching some uh some content
creators the other day rob and they were
like yeah you know it's just not
happening for me and i'm like you've
been at this for four months
like this isn't this doesn't just happen
and so it's so encouraging to hear your
story robin that you know you you
actually do have to go through these
seasons where no one actually sees what
you're doing like was your wife
supportive
in what you were doing did she see the
vision of where this could go oh i think
that's a fantastic question can we just
come on to that a little bit later when
we start yeah about the strategies to
vid iq i think that's a really
interesting thing but yeah i mean to
begin with she was just like yeah it
just seems like a hobby is enjoying it
uh it's not interfering um
with our life you know he seems to find
time and when i'm watching television
like i like i'm winding down rob's
winding down with his video content
creation but yeah there is a clutch
moment there when we have to make a
decision about going full time
i love that so you're creating content
on your own you're working a a job at
this point um now rob you're gonna
transition how in the world do you get
even get started
working with vid iq what did that even
look like for you okay so the story goes
like this we are now
i would say four or five years into my
youtube journey
i've probably done a thousand videos at
this point um
i'm probably around about 20 to 30 000
subscribers
and i feel as if i've learned enough
about youtube that i want to give
something back to my community in terms
of
education this was a bit of an
experiment because i know youtube
education wasn't necessarily
my
niche on my channel but
i always
encourage people to be experimenting on
their channel 20 of a time 10 of a time
so
i started making a few short videos
about youtube education and so if you
just want to share the screen now um
heather that i've put for you i made
this video
as you can see april the 13th 2016 and
it was a very simple one
about
video tags guess what video tags used to
be a little more important for your seo
and
vid iq uh as it still has now
a useful tool for copying somebody
else's video tags and putting them in
your videos i will confess i will
confess this is something i still do
today i search
on youtube things like how to get more
views how to get more subscribers i see
think media at the top of the list i
steal think media's tags i put them in
my own videos i delete the tags that say
think media tv and i replace them with
vidiq i confess i do that it's because
tags aren't that important anymore but i
still feel as if i can take 20 seconds
of my time to put some tags in a video
so i did a tutorial
on how to do this and as you can see i
think i took this screenshot maybe three
or four months ago and the video only
has
4200 views
but
what i did most importantly
is i
tried to advertise the fact that i made
this video to vid iq themselves so as
you can see i posted out this tweet on
exactly the same day and i just said hey
vidiq i made a video about one of your
tools i hope you enjoy it um
thanks and that was it that was a simple
tweet and that tweet literally changed
my life because within i would say 24
hours
the ceo of vid iq rob sandy so yes to
confirm to everybody right now i do not
own vid iq i do not run vid iq i'm not
the co-founder although everybody thinks
i am because that's what tends to happen
with happened with the uh face of a
of a brand um rob sandy contacted me
said i like what you're doing um would
you like to do some freelance work with
us and maybe do some more of his
tutorials and i was a bit flabbergasted
at the time uh i obviously i said yes
and that was the first step from going
as a independent creator earning a bit
of adsense revenue to actually do some
contracted freelance work and the really
funny part of that story was uh rob ask
me this is rob sandy he asked me um so
how much do you charge and i had no idea
how much to charge i had no idea of the
value of myself as a content creator so
i kind of blurted out uh
25 an hour and he actually refused that
offer and he um said no i'm gonna pay
you 45 an hour so that built up an
incredible amount of trust straight out
of the gate that he was valuing me more
than myself
and then the relationship started to
develop from there it was like one or
two videos a week you know two or three
four or five hours a week and that's
where the journey started um in
yeah i guess april 2016 at that point
wow rob we got our journey started
around the exact same time this is
incredible i i'm learning this story at
the same time as the rest of uh you
watching right now and i'm just beaming
because
where you started to where you are now i
mean what do you remember uh how many
subscribers were
when you came onto vid iq as a content
creator do you remember where you were
subscriber-wise for that channel yeah we
had to check this when we hit a million
subscribers uh late last year i think it
was like 1600. from what i can remember
vid iq had one
video on their channel which was like
they used it for google ads and it was a
very highly pub
published one a very highly produced one
back in 2013 but not done anything
until
my video started appearing in 2016. so
virtually nowhere from from scratch more
or less yeah that is amazing and now
vidiq is over a million subscribers and
growing every single day it's incredible
to see what are some things that you did
to help that iq grow because i mean to
go from basically you know a thousand
subscribers 1600 subscribers to a
million in just a few years there had to
be some real strategic things that you
were doing to be able to make that a
reality for the company
so i think there's two parts to this
question there is the part where i was a
freelance
contributor
and then
the full-time youtube creator so maybe
i'll start with the freelance side and
then we can get to the question of um
going full time yeah and what it meant
afterwards
i will say that when i was making
contents
as a freelancer of course i wanted to
create a
professional
well-produced piece of content that was
going to be valuable
for vid iq
but i probably didn't understand
the audience because i was
there was obviously a money a money
motivation to get paid for it but i
wasn't fully committed to vid iq because
i still had my own channel and i was
still making tech videos and that was
starting to really take off at the time
i very quickly went from i think 20 30
000 subscribers to 100 000 subscribers
in a space of about a year 18 months
when i figured out my niche
and so
vidiq was almost a bit of a distraction
at that time you know i was still trying
to find time to work on my channel
and then do this freelancing
gig as well
but what changed i think six months into
the relationship
uh rob asked if he could speak to me and
i thought oh no here we go i think i
think this might be the end of this uh
this relationship i think rob may want
to go in a different direction but it
was completely the opposite he said
we're liking what you're doing we want
you to come on full time
i again i was flabbergasted i couldn't
believe the opportunity that was being
presented to me
but i had a bit of a technical block
because i was living in canada i was on
a certain work visa which wouldn't allow
me to do this
so i said to rob i would love to do this
but i need to figure out my
work situation in canada
and that took up that took a full year
to to figure out we had to go from
a work visa to permanent residency that
application took a year so there's still
a process
of me uh working for vid iq part-time
freelancing and then also my full-time
job
and then also working on my main channel
and there was a year of uh
yeah i guess these different pressures
pulling at me like which direction am i
gonna go
and then finally i think in 2017
i got my permanent residence and i said
to rob okay
i can maybe take this opportunity
forward now uh what's your offer
and um
he made the offer and then i had quite a
big decision to make here because not
only do i have my full-time job which is
very reliable very stable
but i also have this offer from vid iq a
tech startup which has its unknowns you
know it could be it could turn into a
100 million dollar company next year
i'll be out of business next month
uh and then also uh i i have a partner
and we have
you know financial obligations in terms
of rent and things and
i remember i don't know if you have
these i don't think these exist in them
in the us but we went to a white spot uh
and this is like a local restaurant in
bc and i i called it the white spot
summit where we put down all of the pros
and all of the cons
of doing of doing this
and um i think my wife realized that
this was my passion
it's something i love doing i may not
get the opportunity to do this again in
my life considering
how i'd failed before as a writer um
you know i'm into my mid-30s at that
point and she was fully supportive so i
you know i have to say thank you thank
you very much to sarah uh for supporting
me on this
uh and you know five years later it
turned about turned out to be the right
decision um but at the same time i'm
also thinking
i have a channel now that has a hundred
thousand subscribers a tech channel what
if i continue to do that and and go all
in with that you know i start to focus
on marketing myself trying to think
about how i can build a business through
affiliate links adsense sponsorship etc
etc etc
and i just came to the conclusion that
i've always thought of myself as not a
particularly good marketer in terms of
being able to run all of these things
and like have to run a business
so i i don't know if you call it the
easy way out but like
strangely even though leaving my
full-time job and going to vid iq was a
risk it still felt more stable and
reliable than trying them being wholly
dependent on myself to generate all of
this income and revenue
and i now i think five years down the
line did i make the right decision could
my own channel have got to a million
subscribers and be earning me you know
seven figures in income will never know
but i still think i made
the right choice for myself and my
partner
man rob there's so much self-awareness
in just talking about that piece of your
journey one uh it's not too late right
you're like i failed at some other
things but it wasn't too late to say i
see this opportunity i see where this is
going but one of the key things that you
said there was that you did have to
weigh the option of do you go all in and
bet on yourself 100
or do you work with the team and do you
grow something that's bigger than you
and you know for for me too rob i i my
journey and your journey are so
overlapping in a lot of the pieces um
and i think that more creators
should be looking at ways if they're not
the marketer they're not the business
person they're not the leader but they
love creating content there is going to
be a massive opportunity here in the
future with youtube channels likevidiq
like think media looking for content
creators who have shown that they
understand youtube you did that right
you showed you understood youtube but
that you could also be a great team
player and help the whole company rise
it's so so encouraging to hear that um
and congratulations again i know that
you know 1 million subscribers is just
the number but it to me it represents
from being on the other side with you
that's so much hard work that's one
video at a time that's all the you know
oh no the audio wasn't working and did i
say that right in the video and why is
my hair messed up that's all of that and
i and i see that gold play button behind
you and to me like that's like our
olympic medal like we did it we did all
the training and all the things um i do
wish though rob don't you think there
should be like a 2 million or a 5
million i mean now we got to go to 10
million to get the next reward yeah that
could take a while and yeah i i
apologize to everyone i've still not
found a convenient place to put this so
it's just shoved in there and it's now
turning into a running joke uh but
hey hey ho what can you say um for the
studio upgrade that'll happen sometimes
you'll have a great place for for that
to happen well rob i want to ask um
because you know we we do work from home
what a blessing we get to work from home
some people don't like that i thrive in
working from home um
i i actually am more of an introvert i
don't know are you an introvert as well
definitely 100 like um
going to conferences
uh is socially exhausting for me not
that i serve at the highly valuable and
very useful but
yeah
and i don't know how i'm going to cope
with the next one after the pandemic
because now i haven't really been in a
space with more than 10 people for
two years at this point yeah i i am i'm
feeling the same way of like okay we're
gonna go back out there i have to like
prep myself up um we get to work from
home i i would love for people to know
every day obviously can be different
especially as a creator right there's
there's all these different things but
what is what is a typical day for a
full-time youtuber what was your title
rob that you said you are what's your
title it's youtuber in residence but
it's just a play on words from you know
poet in residence at university
essentially i'm the content creator for
a for a youtube channel i i think i'm
gonna make you a shirt that says
youtuber in residence um what does a
typical day look like for you so i think
this is where we can go back to the to
the question of like going from an
independent contractor for a company to
working full-time for them
i think what was really important um
for how
this has been a success with me at vid
iq
is that um
i have com pretty much complete creative
control over the channel there's very
little interference and input from uh
management of vid iq because i think
after my trial
of a year year and a half just making
videos rob trusted me to um to to do a
good job on the channel and i think that
is so important
to to have that feeling of um creative
ownership and it allows me to be
authentic and real not necessarily be a
salesperson for vid iq i mean i've often
wrestled with this question myself like
do i do enough
calls to action and selling of a vid iq
product on the channel
and i'm not sure if i do but nobody's
ever told me i don't so i i feel as if i
must be doing a good job building a
community
vid iq
and it's also made me feel responsible
for the channel and it's given me
ownership and made me care about the
vidiq channel as if it was my own
and that allowed me to kind of mothball
my own channel i i for about six months
after i went full time
i tried to run both vid iq and my tech
channel and i just couldn't do it
because
the transference of
um
of the struggle was going from
physically being exhausted from doing a
full-time job in life and then trying to
make youtube videos to be mentally
exhausted where i'm at
the vid iq you know office so to speak
making content for the channel thinking
about youtube
all day but i just don't have any mental
capacity to put it into my own channel
so that was the tough um decision i made
fun story though four years after making
my last video i'm still learning about
ten dollars a day on that channel
hashtag passion passive income that is
incredible
but going on to
like the average day a vid iq i think
for me literally it is being a content
creator
keeping
up to speed with what's going on in the
world of youtube and trying to determine
what information that youtube sending
out is going to be
relevant and valuable to our audience in
terms of youtube education
it's also
continuing to look at how i've developed
as a youtube educator and what i can add
to what i've already spoken about like
we've done
multiple videos now on how to get a
thousand subscribers but each one
provides new
insights both from me learning about
youtube but also
from me as a better content creator
uh it's doing these live it's doing live
streams uh it's networking just like i'm
doing with you now heather trying to uh
get into the youtube space and
collaborate with people but of course
there are also boring things like
attending meetings and doing expenses
i i think the the one thing i probably
do
as
[Music]
the one thing i do most beyond content
creation is contributing to the
development of vid iq tools
because when i first joined vidiq i
think i was the first creator to be on
the vidiq staff so then i could now
start to
influence how the product develops
through the eyes of the content creator
and we have we now have several uh
creators on there uh so yeah we're
trying to make sure that we
um offer our
um advice on what we would like as
creators
uh beyond just i guess the technical
aspects of
here's what we want
and then we get pushback from the
developers saying here's what we can
build and then we kind of reach a happy
compromise usually
i love that so much and what is smart um
what i just i i so
love seeing companies that understand
what's really happening and what's
really happening is that youtube is a
real thing and obviously vid iq being on
the backbone of youtube itself the
software company
what an incredibly smart thing to
actually have their own creators using
their products and not just not just
using it but like talking about it
building around it and what a great
insight into what they are doing i wanna
i wanna switch really quick rob because
we have so many people i saw someone in
here that said just hit my first
thousand subscribers um let's see uh
swedish said i just made my first 100
subscribers this month uh i saw natalie
heels was getting ready and is about to
uh
yes just hit 300 subs so we have so many
new youtubers um that are starting and
and i i get so giddy and excited when
people are just getting started um
you've been at this now for a while rob
what advice do you have to the people
who are just starting their own channel
and then i want to switch and say what
advice do you have for people who want
to actually work for a company like
vidiq or think media or other channels
that are looking for creators to help
build out these giant businesses
yeah so i always like to preface uh
the advice given here is my advice and i
think over um
creators who've gone full time and have
gone through their own journeys will
probably have their own slants on what
they um they think people should do
starting their channels
but mine is pretty simple it is start
your channel
now
today
if you're thinking about it stop
thinking do
rather than think
i believe you need to figure out if you
love being a creator just making content
day after day after day
as quickly as possible and then would
you love
doing what you're doing today as you
start in a year's time
even if by then you still haven't made a
single dollar and that's pretty much my
attitude to begin with
it was
i would say
two or three years before i started to
make any kind of significant income you
know over over a hundred dollars a month
and i think once you've figured out that
that you just love creating you love
um finding an audience and making a
positive impact on their lives start to
invest that passion and enthusiasm
into developing your craft you know
starting to think smarter as well as um
working hard and getting to know your
space your video topic and then the
people within it after a few years of
creating i just started to research what
tools are going to help me vidiq was one
of them and then
almost subconsciously by making this
content and posting that tweet i was
saying to the youtube universe hey
i want to take this seriously i want to
take this full time
how do i get this to happen and
here i am now five years later so my
advice to anybody who wants to work for
a company in youtube or by extension if
you want to get noticed by a a large
creator on youtube
think about
what value
you could
uniquely offer that creator and their
audience
and then do it for
free
at the same time i think what your the
content that you're making or the thing
that you're doing for free it should
have some
connection back to
your audience
i've seen a couple of examples where
there are craft channels that do amazing
things like epoxy resin creations and
they'll they'll make something
incredible and they'll do it for mr
beast or another creator and that's kind
of like
their their connection to that creator
and if you're good at it
and uh enough people uh are saying wow
this is fantastic and they're sharing it
around then i think the the larger
creator or indeed the company that
you're trying to get a hold of is going
to start notice and maybe it's going to
take a couple of efforts maybe it's
going to take you know three or four
videos or or two or three different
creations um but i think just
i feel as if you have to demonstrate
what you're capable of first rather than
just like a cold call email so to speak
like show demonstrate what you're good
at
and try and involve that creator all
that business in the thing that you're
trying to demonstrate
so much great advice in that rob we had
people that were like i'm getting so
many gems out of this episode if you got
value from uh rob today and just hearing
his journey and just the little nuggets
that he was talking about about how he
went from being a you know uh um well i
don't want to point at this rob but you
know i'm a marketer so a failed writer
into being a youtube dominator right and
and uh yeah like can we say that rob i
mean i i i was
failed creative like i i was interested
in writing i went to university
i was looking to get into writing and
just the constant failure it kind of
sucked all of the creativity out of me
and then i just started doing the nine
to five job and within a couple of years
that creativity was rekindled and the
spark was youtube
so good so good uh let us know what your
aha moment was from this interview with
rob you can catch rob actually over on
the vid iq channel you're posting videos
every single week you guys are doing uh
live streams where you are uh doing
channel reviews for different uh size
channels over there and you can get your
free offer of uh vid iq if you go to
vidiq.com forward slash think and
actually rob we're going to be doing
some incredible giveaways
of vidiq's products during our five day
free challenge we have a free youtube
challenge coming up to help people get
to their first
000 subscribers and in their first 1 000
on youtube if you're not signed up for
that already you better get over there
because we're going to be giving away
some incredible prizes uh gifts from vid
iq as one of our sponsors for this
challenge you can register at
tube1kchallenge.com
rob it has been such an incredible um
time i got to spend with you uh thank
you so much for coming on the youtube
made simple show thanks for being a
regular contributor um to what we're
doing here at think media i think it's
just incredible that um that your
journey has inspired so many people to
start their youtube journey rob and
we're just getting started we're on our
way to 10 million right we're on our way
to uh
all the things and uh and i just want to
say thank you so much for uh being on
the show today it's been a pleasure and
uh i actually got
a little bit emotional when i was
talking about um
the point where you know speaking to my
wife and how she supported me so you
know what i'm going to do right after
this live stream i'm going to give her a
hug and a kiss and say thank you oh i
love that so much that is
man it when you have to make big hard
decisions like that into the unknown
it's good to have a partner with you who
believes in what you're doing and who
you are so i love that rob well i want
to thank you so much for being a part of
what we're doing here at think media
make sure you register for that free
five day youtube challenge this is a
brand new challenge that you don't want
to miss it's starting in just a few days
so you want to make sure you get
registered and you'll get all the
details over at
tube1kchallenge.com this is a free
challenge where you can learn how to get
your first 1000 subscribers and beyond
we're going to be breaking it down with
myself sean cannell and the think media
team we have amazing prizes where we're
going to be giving away things like
cameras and microphones and vin iq
memberships and so much more so make
sure you sign up for the tube 1k
challenge and invite a friend you have a
friend who needs to start youtube as
well get them to the challenge thank you
so much for being a part of what we're
doing at think media if you want to
catch another interview with someone
from the youtube made simple show you
can click or tap the screen right now or
if you want to check out another video
from our podcast you can click or tap
the screen right now thanks so much for
watching we'll catch you next time bye